[Applaus]
herr präsident
frau bundeskanzlerin meine damen und
herren es gibt eine einfache lösung die
zahl der verkehrsunfall toten auf null
zu senken
mannschaft den straßenverkehr ab
bekanntlich tun wir das nicht sondern
wir wägen ab welchen preis sogar an
menschenleben zahlen wir für welchen
nutzen
deshalb gibt es den straßenverkehr
obwohl dort menschen sterben menschen
sterben auch an krankheiten jeden tag
das ist leider so wenn wir auf die
aktuellen corona lage blicken lassen
sich zwei feststellungen treffen ja
erstens das infektionsgeschehen ist
nicht mehr kontrollierbar zweitens es
gibt dennoch vergleichsweise wenige tote
derzeit steht täglich an die niedrige
bis mittlere zweistellige zahl von
menschen an oder mit 19
daraus folgernd manche dass das virus
nicht besonders gefährlich ist
tatsächlich verhält es sich so dass es
für die meisten menschen nicht besonders
gefährlich ist
ich grüße an dieser stelle der
bundesgesundheitsminister dessen
infektion offenbar erfreulich milden
verlauf nehmen aber für einige menschen
ja das ist richtig
ist das virus hochgefährlich oder gar
tödlich das führt uns zum gleichnis der
verkehrsunfälle zurück man hat ihre zahl
durch alkoholverbote
geschwindigkeitsbegrenzungen in
ortschaften und anderen maßnahmen
reduziert ohne den verkehr zu verbieten
das müssen wir nun auf die korona krise
übertragen
augenscheinlich stecken sich vor allem
aktive und jüngere menschen also solche
die eine infektion gut verkraften können
oder mitunter gar nicht bemerken diese
zeitgenossen brauchen keinen schutz
und es muss ihnen nichts verboten werden
wir müssen stattdessen die risikogruppen
definieren und schützen
ich habe hier schon einmal besondere
einkaufszeiten für senioren und
chronisch kranke vorgeschlagen meine
damen und herren es gibt übrigens auch
opfer über die niemand spricht nämlich
die collateral opfer der antike oder
maßnahmen isolierte alte depressive
sozial schwache und nicht zuletzt unsere
kinder die qualität des schulunterrichts
sie durch ausfallstunden hausunterricht
und ständiges masken tragen und das in
einem land das keinen anderen rohstoff
besitzt als die bildung
meine damen und herren frau
bundeskanzlerin angst ist ein schlechter
ratgeber
das tägliche infektionszahlen
bombardement soll aber den menschen
offenbar angst machen weil die meisten
im alltag nichts von coop 19 sehen
entschuldigung aber es handelt sich um
eine art agenda
wozu ja aufpasst dass wir neuerdings von
einer art kriegs kabinett dem corona
kabinett regiert werden
es hat die größten
freiheitsbeschränkungen in der
geschichte dieser republik beschlossen
im namen der gesundheit der bürger
herr lauterbach stellt in einem
interview mit der rheinischen post nun
sogar die unverletzlichkeit der wohnung
zur disposition
mit verlaub meine damen und herren
schnappen die allmählich über wo im
grundgesetz aber steht geschrieben dass
die regierungschefin zusammen mit den
ministerpräsidenten am parlament vorbei
solche entscheidungen treffen darf
souverän ist wer über den
ausnahmezustand befindet heißt es bei
karl schmidt darf ich sie daran erinnern
dass der souverän dieses landes das
deutsche volk ist repräsentiert durch
den bundestag und allein dieses haus hat
über grundrechts einschränkung zu
befinden und sonst niemand sonst sind
wir exakt wieder gespielt
wir betrachten die von frau merkel
verkündete lahmlegung des kulturbetriebs
der gastronomie ja praktisch des
gesamten freizeit lebens der bürger als
maßlos und unangemessen für die
konzertsäle um nur ein beispiel zu
nennen werden heute schon ausschließlich
online tickets verkauft jeder besucher
wird registriert nach auskunft des
präsidenten des deutschen bühnenvereins
gibt es keinen einzigen nachgewiesenen
fall einer corona infektion nach
veranstaltungsbesuchern auf deutschen
bühnen und auch ein normaler
restaurantbesuch unter einhaltung der
aha regengebiet keinen neuen hotspot
ich möchte sie frau bundeskanzlerin
ausdrücklich vor einem zweiten lockdown
der wirtschaft war das verkraften wir
nicht wir müssen abwägen welchen preis
wir bereits hin zu zahlen
dieser preis ist zu hoch und vor allem
zahlen in diejenigen die alles richtig
gemacht haben die kleinen restaurant
hotel betreiber neben der klassische
deutsche mittelstand den sie gerade
dabei sind zu ruinieren
wir verlangen daher dass das parlament
wieder vollständig in seiner rechte
eingesetzt wird hier in diesem hause
soll über maßnahmen gegen die pandemie
entschieden werden und nirgendwo sonst
eine cola diktatur auf wiederum verträgt
sich nicht mit unserer freiheitlich
demokratischen grundordnung unsere welt
verändert sich auf erschreckende weise
in richtung unfreiheit eine neue werte
hierarchie entsteht weg für eine
individuelle entscheidung und hin zu
kollektivem organisiert organisationen
meine damen und herren wir haben in
diesem land die freiheit zu mühselig
aromen als dass wir sie an der garderobe
eines notstands des kabinetts abgeben
eine corona diktatur auf widerruf ist
keine lösung wir müssen abwägen auch um
den preis dass menschen sterben
das leben ist der güter höchstes nicht
sagte airport von messina
er hat recht die güter höchstes ist die
freiheit freiheit in würde würde der
herr bundestagspräsidenten hinzufügen
ich bedanke mich meine damen
[Applaus]